no he chose not to testify in defence
but that jury as you mentioned have now
been sent out to begin their
deliberations of what they've heard over
the course of the past six weeks here at
the federal courthouse in brooklyn new
york a case which centers on r kelly
real name robert kelly one of the most
successful r b music stars of a
generation a winner of three grammy
awards now the federal prosecutors here
have accused the singer of sexually
abusing more than 20 girls boys and
women over the course of more than two
decades many of whom were teenagers at
the time of those alleged offences now
robert kelly is charged with nine
separate offenses the most serious of
which is a racketeering charge the
prosecution case that they put forward
was that he ran a form of criminal
enterprise that he used his business
associates the likes of bodyguards
agents and runners in order to
facilitate this lifestyle in order to
procure young women for him to have sex
with and then cover up his crimes
central to that racketeering charge is
his relationship with fellow music star
aaliyah aliyah died in a plane crash 20
years ago but the prosecution cases that
while she was alive r kelly both groomed
and sexually abused her central to that
racketeering charge is that he um bribed
an official in order to get a fake id to
marry elia when she was just 15 years
old believing that she was pregnant at
the time and that that he could then
compel her to get an abortion r kelly is
also accused of the lesser charges but
still very serious charges of kidnapping
and crossing state lines for the
purposes of prostitution it's been an
incredibly disturbing six weeks of
testimony and women who have taken the
stand have told how he locked them in
rooms how they had to ask for permission
even to go to the bathroom and how um
they were beaten by r kelly as a form of
punishment the jury now considering
whether he's guilty of racketeering all
the eight other offences of which he is
charged whatever way this case goes the
music industry and indeed law
enforcement also stand accused of
turning a blind eye to the allegations
against our kelly for far too long
martha in new york thank you